the millions of people in East Africa
are facing an impending disaster swarms
of locusts are ravaging fields of crops
the UN is calling for urgent actions
saying the food security of people in
the affected region is at risk more
rainfall in the weeks ahead will bring
fresh vegetation to feed new generations
of the pests efforts to contain the
pests in wingy
in central Kenya experts say there's
just a short window to prevent the worst
these locusts are still on the ground
they're feeding and grouping together
but it's only a matter of time before
they're able to fly it's time for the
international community to understand
that it is an issue that needs to be
dealt with now otherwise we will turn a
situation of a plague there will be high
level of acute food insecurity there
will be million more people that will
require food assistance and it will take
us years to control this situation once
the swamp can fly it becomes difficult
to control the insects desert locust can
cover distances of up to 200 kilometers
a day the insects are constantly
multiplying each female locust can lay
about 100 eggs after two weeks millions
of new hoppers emerged and the cycle
goes on and on and on
and so I just think of a swarm that
covers Manhattan from the south up to
the north and this is just a
medium-sized swarm it's not really a big
swarm for desert locusts that swarm in
one day can eat the same amount of food
as the entire population of Kenya with
unusual rainfalls at this time of the
year the breeding conditions are
extremely favorable for the locusts and
extremely unfavorable for farmers this
what we heavily depend on this farming
season we have to but even if the one
beginning in April is short and notice
productive we depend a lot on this one
we worried that the locusts will destroy
our harvest and we end up going hungry
the rest of the
waiting for October when we have the
next cropping season after devastating
large areas in Somalia Ethiopia and
Kenya the swamps have now reached Uganda
and are threatening South Sudan in
Tanzania